What is NAC? NAC is an acetylcystine. I wouldn't have been good for a person who has estrogen-driven breast cancer.
So, an acetylcystine is a precursor for glutathione. So that's why would you take an acetylcystine?
A person would take an acetylcystine for the purpose of increasing glutathione reduction in the cells. So, what is glutathione?
So, don't confuse glutathione with glutamine, or the words sound the same. They are not even close to the same thing, completely different.
So, glutathione is the main intracellular antioxidant. So, if ever, we're exposed to oxidizing agents.
Oxidizing agents have a purpose in our body. If everything is at all good, yours are all bad.
So, you hear about oxidizing agents. Oh, that's all bad. Well, it's not all bad. You need oxidizing agents to kill bacteria, to help you kill bacteria, to help kill viruses.
It's good to have oxidizing agents, but once a virus gets inside the cell and causes an oxidation that's going on and damages the cell so you want antioxidants inside the cell.
glutathione is your main antioxidant inside of a cell. One of the issues with oxidizing agents is that we're exposed to a lot of oxidizing agents. Oxidizing agents are poisons.
So, poisons, toxins, heavy metals, pesticides, herbicides, all those things are oxidizing agents.
They're in abundance, and they can damage cell membranes. They can damage causing cancer. They can get inside a cell and damage the nucleus causing cancer. They can cause death of a cell.
They can damage the mitochondria. They can damage other organelles in the cell. They can wreak havoc, and people would argue that our exposure to the high level of oxidizing agents is a cause of majority of our illness.
It's a cause of majority of our ill health today that our ancestors never experienced. And that is true. So our body, we're made, God created us to have an antioxidant system.
Inside the cell, there's multiple, but the main one is the production and recycling of glutathione. It's so important that you don't just you don't burn through glutathione, you recycle glutathione.
Well, cysteine is an amino acid that is essential to help recycle glutathione. So, glutathione is used to break down an oxidant, and therefore it's reduced that it needs to be recycled again in order to be reactivated to be used again.
So, cysteine is an important amino acid to help with glutathione production and recycling of glutathione. That's etacetal cysteine.
So, should a person with cancer take etacetal cysteine?
So, back to understanding glutathione. So, is etacetal cysteine an important thing to take for a person with cancer, or a person that has a lot of oxidizing agents?
A person that has been exposed to a lot of toxins, a person that is exposed to mold, a person that has been exposed to glyphosate.
Well, to me, it's one step better than taking etacetal cysteine would be taking glutathione. The problem is that in years past, glutathione was very poorly absorbed.
The form of the forms of glutathione we had in the 80s, 90s, and early 2000s, just wasn't worth really taking, you didn't absorb it.
We used to have people put it in water and then nebulize it. That was much better absorbed, but now we have better forms of glutathione.
In the capsule form, we have good forms of glutathione. Any good supplement company will use these better forms.
And even the best form of glutathione is liposomal glutathione, very well absorbed. So, even bypassing the recycling process, you're increasing glutathione stores and cells.
glutathione is essential inside every cell and in the liver to help you detoxify places.
Back to should every person be taking glutathione or etacetal cysteine.
Well, it depends. If a person is doing chemotherapy, then they should not be doing glutathione or etacetal cysteine or any glutathione or antioxidants that during, at least, the 48 hour window after the IV.
Because you're now negating chemotherapy is an oxidized agent. So, someone happy that balance, but can someone who's not doing the chemotherapy take glutathione?
Yes, doesn't mean that every person on the planet should be taking glutathione or etacetal cysteine.
Not necessarily. You do get it in your foods. Cysteine is an amino acid. It's an animal proteins and a plant protein.
So, again, it's like you could be overload of all the supplements that you're taking. I don't want people to have that issue either.